[Music]
you've seen Thor the film that tided
fans over until the Avengers now
experience the film that will Thai fans
over until the Avengers to Thor the dark
world the war is back in another
perfectly adequate Marvel movie that
pleasantly killed a few hours of your
time with enough cool visuals action and
humor to keep you from wondering why
does the Elfman want to shoot magic
kool-aid into the sky holes return for
another post Avengers movie full of
references to the Avengers but no actual
Avengers instead of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes watch Thor team up once again
with Heimdall the watchful Guardian who
can see everything except for the spy
and Thor's girlfriend the concert and
this gigantic spaceship directly above
em the warriors three who are so
replaceable they switched out one of the
actors and you totally didn't notice and
everyone's favorite Loki the charismatic
trickster who no one should trust by now
you still don't trust me brother with
you no idiot when he's not battling yet
another forgettable bad guy watch as the
Mighty Thor mopes around Asgard in the
Snuggie because he still hung up on a
girl he spent one long weekend with and
hasn't called in two years
where were you Natalie Portman returns
as Jean Grey from the x-men Phoenix saga
with the help of her wacky sidekick her
other wacky sidekick and her other wacky
sidekicks wacky psychic they´ll
discovered the converges a piece of
science mumbo-jumbo everyone keeps
to explain once a cycle all the world's
align the alignment is only temporary he
must be in exactly the right place the
right time because it's is gonna go
ballistic increases and decreases in
gravity spatial extrusions whatever can
we just see Thor hit something with a
hammer again thank you travel across the
nine realms ranging from Earth to
vanaheim to subs but of portal to Asgard
home of the most penetrable impenetrable
city ever
so right along with the god of thunder
they are not God so right along with the
guy of thunder for another celebration
of the male form in all its beauty
featuring as Jewish and pixilated balls
starring Gail's brother Natalie Portman
for Loki goldeneye the Nutty Professor
and Oscar Ken Jennings Stanley and
Bugatti Thor the dark world now you're
thinking with portals a screen junkies
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers nobody makes me bleed my own
blood
whoever girl scruple monkey giggle
bottoms why do these people keep telling
me to say things that don't make sense
King Kong and gush on me